hello everyone and welcome to this
interesting video tutorial by simply
learn today we are going to perform two
hands-on projects on covet data analysis
using python and tableau
this is going to be a really interesting
and fun session where i'll be asking you
a few generic quiz questions related to
coronavirus please make sure to answer
them in the comment section of the video
we'll be happy to hear from you covet or
coronavirus is an ongoing global
pandemic of coronavirus disease that
emerged in 2019 and was first identified
in wuhan china
it is defined as an illness caused by a
novel coronavirus called severe acute
respiratory syndrome
2
commonly known as sars cove 2
on march 11 2020 the who declared coven
19 a global health emergency the virus
has so far infected over 22 crore people
and killed more than 4.5 million
innocents
in india there have been over 3.3 crore
confirmed cases and nearly
4 lakh 41 000 deaths have been reported
so far
this data is according to official
figures released by the union ministry
of health and family welfare
as the world tries to cope up with this
deadly virus we request all our viewers
and their family members to follow all
the necessary precautions to avoid
getting infected
quiz time now let's see our first quiz
in this project
what does corona in corona virus mean
here are the options is it a beer
b respiratory is it c crown or is it d
sun
this is a very general question i'm sure
a lot of you may already know some of
you may not
please let us know your answers in the
comment section of the video we'll be
glad to hear from you
now in this video we will use
three different kuvin19 datasets and
perform data analysis using python and
tableau
the project will give you hands-on
experience working on real-world data
sets and how you can use the different
python libraries to analyze and
visualize data and draw conclusions
you will learn how to create different
plots in tableau and then make a
dashboard from the visuals
the project will give you an idea about
the impact of coronavirus globally in
terms of confirmed cases that's reported
the number of recoveries as well as
active cases
we will also see how india has been
affected since the pandemic started and
dive into the different states and union
territories to learn more about the
covet 19 influence and the vaccination
status
first let me show you the two data sets
that we'll be using
so for our first project using python
we'll be using the first two data sets
kovid 19 india and covet vaccine
statewise
let me open the two data sets
okay
so this is the first data set you can
see here
we have
the date
we have the time then we have the
different state names
but scroll down you can see we have
kerala tamil nadu delhi haryana
rajasthan
sladhak punjab
telangana and other states
then we have something called as
confirmed indian national so actually
this
two data sets confirmed indian national
and confirmed foreign national we won't
be using so in the demo itself we'll be
dropping these two columns
what we are concerned about are the last
three columns
the
cured cases or the recoveries
the number of deaths reported and then
we have the
total number of confirmed cases
let me just
sort the b column that is the date
column so that you have an idea
about the recent data we have
i'll continue with the current selection
and
sort it you can see here
this is till
11th of august 2021
so this data was collected from kegel it
has some discrepancies that we will see
in the demo the data is available for
free
we will provide the link to the data
sets in the description of the video so
please go ahead and download them
the visualizations and results that you
will see in the demo are based on the
datasets that we'll be using we haven't
pre-processed the data to remove
outliers or any missing values
now before i jump into the demo let me
show you the second data set that we are
going to use
okay so coveted vaccine state wise is my
second data set
let me open it
there you go
so
this is the second data set that we'll
be using in the python
project you can see we have a column
called updated on then we have the
state again you can see here there are a
few discrepancies here
it has taken the country name and not
the state name below you can see there
are the
different state names
and
you can also see we have information
about the total doses administered
we have the sessions sites
first dose administered then we have the
second dose
then we have information about male and
female doses
you can see here the different
vaccines
administered covaxian and cova shield
you have sputnik v
and here are the different age groups as
well
and finally if you see we have
male individuals vaccinated the total
number of female individuals vaccinated
for a particular day
we have information about transgender
individuals vaccinated and finally we
have the total individuals vaccinated
each day
all right before we jump into the
hands-on part let's have a look at the
second quiz in this project
so
here is the second quiz question
which is the first country to start
covid vaccination for toddlers
is it a japan b israel c portugal or is
it d cuba
this is a very recent development that
took place if you watch daily news
updates on coronavirus you will be
definitely able to answer the question
please give it a try and put your
answers in the comments section of the
video it is really important for our
viewers to know the right answer
all right
so now let's begin
with our demo
so i am on my jupyter notebook
so the first project we are going to use
python jupyter notebook
i'll just
rename this notebook as
kovid
data analysis
project
and click on rename
all right
so first and foremost
we need to import all the necessary
libraries that we are going to use so
first i am importing pandas as pd this
is for
data manipulation
then we have numpy as np
numpy is used for numerical computation
then we are importing
matplotlib c bond and plotly
these three libraries will be used for
plotting our data and creating
interesting visualizations finally i'm
also importing
my date time
function
all right
so i'll hit shift enter to run the first
cell
now it's time
to load our first data set
which is related to
the kovate 19 cases in india for the
different states and union territories
so i'll create a variable called covet
underscore df df is for data frame
i'll use my pandas library
and then
give the read underscore csv function
since our data sets are
csv files
and inside
double quotes i'll pass in the
location where my
data sets are present
so i'll just copy this location
i'll paste it here
we'll change
the backslash to forward slash
and after that i'm going to give my
file name followed by the extension of
the file
i'll say
19
india dot csv
let's go ahead and run it
all right
now
to see the first few
rows of the data frame i'm going to use
the head function
i'll say head and within
brackets let's say i
pass in 10 which means i want to see the
first 10 rows of data
if i run it there you go
here you can see from 0
till 9 so we have 10 rows of information
and these are the different
column names you have s number
date time state or union territory then
you have confirmed indian national
confirmed foreign national
cured cases deaths reported and the
confirmed cases
all right
now moving ahead let's use the
info function to get some idea about
a data set
if i run it you can see here
it gives us the
total number of columns we have nine
columns the total number of entries or
the rows we have eighteen thousand
hundred and ten rows of information
starting from zero till
eighteen thousand one hundred and nine
you see here the different types of
variables or column names that we have
then it has information about the memory
usage as well
and this side you can see
the data types
cool
now we'll use another very important
function which is
to get
some idea about statistical analysis the
basic statistics about your data set for
that i will be using the describe
function
okay
so if you can see here
the describe function is for
numerical columns only
and you have the measures such as count
the mean standard deviation
maximum minimum the
25th percentile 50th percentile and the
75th percentile value
okay
now let's move ahead and import the
second data set which is related to
vaccination
so i'll create a variable called vaccine
underscore df
i'll write pd dot
read underscore csv function which is
present in pandas
library i'll move to the top and i'll
copy the
file location
and we'll change the name of the file
copy this and
let me paste it here
and instead of covet underscore 19
underscore india
i'm going to say governed
underscore
vaccine
underscore
statewide
okay
so this is the data set that we saw
covered underscore vaccine underscore
state wise
all right
let me run it
cool
and
let's display the first
seven rows of information from this data
frame
i'll be using the head function and
inside the function i'll pass in seven
there you go so here you can see we have
from 0 till 6 there are total
24 columns
a lot of them have null values you can
see here
all right
now
from the first data set which is the
covered underscore df data frame we'll
be dropping a few
unnecessary
columns such as the time column
confirmed indian national and confirmed
foreign national as well as the s number
we do need these columns so it's better
to learn how to drop the columns for our
analysis
so i'll say
kovid underscore df
dot
i'll use the
drop function
and within square brackets i'll pass in
the column names the first is s number
i'll give a comma
within double quotes i'll say the next
column is time
my third column that i want to drop is
confirmed
indian national
give another comma
within double quotes i'll say
confirmed
foreign national
outside the
square brackets i'll give another comma
and pass in my next
argument
that is in place equal to i'll say true
i'll give another comma and say
access
equal to 1
let's run it
ok it has thrown an error let's debug
the error says confirmed indian okay it
should be indian national and not indian
nation
i'll just
mention it as national will run it again
okay
now we have
removed these four columns
let me show you the data set now
there you go so we have only the date
column state or union territory cured
that's and confirmed
now
let's see how you can change the format
of the
date column for that you have the
function called to datetime
i'll say
covid underscore df
i'll pass in my column name that is date
i'll say equal to
pd dot
i'll use the pandas function that is to
underscore
date time
i'll say covet underscore df which is my
data frame name
pass in my
variable which is date
give a comma
and i'll use my argument that is format
equal to
i'll say percentage y
give a dash say percentage
m
give another dash and say percentage d
let's run it
and i'll print
the head of the data frame
cool
now moving ahead
now we will see how to
find the total number of active cases
so active case is nothing but the total
number of confirmed cases minus the sum
of
cure cases plus that's reported
so let's
find the active cases i'll give a
comment
okay
i'll first write my
data frame name that is covered
underscore df
within square brackets i'll give my new
column which is active underscore
cases
i'll say equal to
kubit underscore df
and my first column would be
the confirmed cases column
minus
i'll say
kovid underscore df
then i'll pass in my cured column
plus
i'll again say
kovid
underscore df
and
add my deaths column
this time let's print
the last
five rows from the new
data frame that we have created
okay
let's run it
it has thrown an error let's debug it
says
dataframe object has no attribute tails
this should be
teal
there you go
you can see here we have added a new
column called active cases which is
the confirmed cases minus the sum of
cured and
deaths reported column
now we will learn how to create a pivot
table using the pandas
library
so in this table we'll be
summing all the
confirmed deaths and
cured
cases
for each of the states and union
territories
so we'll be using the pivot underscore
table function for this
i'll create a variable called statewise
and say pd dot
i'll use the pivot underscore table
function
i'll pass in my
data frame that is kobit underscore df
and then
i'll give my values parameter
inside the square brackets i'll pass in
my
columns
confirmed
deaths
and then we'll have the
cure column
give a comma
and next
argument would be index
which is going to be my state
slash
the union territory column
let me bring this to the next line so it
is more readable
i'll say union territory
i will
give a comma now
and pass in my last argument which is
agg
function that means aggregate function
and
this function would be max
all right
let's run it
okay
now
i'm going to find out the
recovery rate
so recovery rate is basically
the total number of qr cases divided by
the total number of confirmed cases into
100
so i'll say
statewise
and within
square brackets i'll
pass in my
variable that i want to create which is
recovery rate
this will be equal to
[Music]
the
cured cases
multiplied by 100
by the total number of
confirmed cases
within square brackets i'll give my
column as confirmed
let's run this
okay
i'll just copy this column
paste it here so this time we are going
to find out the mortality rate
so mortality rate is nothing but the
total number of deaths divided by the
total number of confirmed cases into
hundred
so i'm just going to
replace the
names here i'll say
mortality
all right
and then instead of cured i'll say
my deaths column
in 200 divided by the confirmed cases
let's run it
okay now
we are going to
sort the values
based on the confirmed cases column
and we will sort it in descending order
so let me show you how to do it i'll say
statewide equal to
i'll use the function short underscore
values
so
i'll pass in my variable statewise dot
and use the
short underscore
values function i'll say by
i want to sort it by my confirmed
cases column
give a comma and i'll say
ascending
equal to
false
let's run it
now we are going to plot our pivot table
using a nice
visual so for that i am going to use
my
background underscore gradient function
and inside that function we'll pass in
our cmap parameter
i'll show you how to do it
say style dot
background
underscore
gradient
and inside this will pass in a
parameter called cmap
so c map stands for color maps this is
present inside the matplotlib library so
here you can see there is a nice
documentation on choosing color maps in
matplotlib
this is provided by matplotlib.org
if i scroll down you can see there are a
number of c maps that you can use
purples blues
you have something called reds
there are other things like magma you
have summer autumn spring winter
cool
all these
you can use whichever color map that you
want and here you can see the different
shades
or the gradients
okay
so i am going to use
my color map as cube helix
let me run it and show you the
pivot table
there you go
here you can see we have our pivot table
ready
now as i said in the beginning there are
a few
discrepancies in the data set so here
you can see
there's one called maharashtra and
there's also maharashtra triple star
this you can ignore
even if i scroll down you have madhya
pradesh followed by three asterisks you
can ignore this value as well even for
bihar we have
so these have been duplicated
and
here you can see the different
state names and union territories then
on the top you have the confirmed cases
cured cases
the debts reported and the new
columns that we created
these are calculated columns recovery
rate and mortality rate
and we have ordered it in
descending order of confirmed cases so
so far
our data says that maharashtra has the
highest number of cases followed by
kerala karnataka tamil nadu andhra
pradesh and uttar pradesh so these are
the top
five states which have the highest
number of
confirmed cases even if you see the
mortality rate is also high for
maharashtra
and
if i scroll down
the mortality rate is also high for
uttarakhand if you see here
if i scroll further
your punjab the mortality rate is also
high
all right
so this was our first
visual that we created in the
kobe data analysis project
now moving ahead
we'll see the
top 10 states based on the number of
active cases
so we'll start
i'll give a comment top 10
active
cases
states
okay
so
we are going to explore another very
important pandas function in this which
is known as
group by
so i'll first
pass in my data frame which is kovid
underscore df
dot followed by the group by function
i am going to group my data based on
state slash
union territory column
then i'll say
dot
max which is to find the
maximum value from the states
that have
the highest
active cases so i have passed in my
active cases column
and
we're also going to group it
based on the date column
after that
we are going to sort the values so i'll
use my function that is sort underscore
values
i'll say
short by
my column that is
active cases
let me bring this to the next line
underscore
cases
i'll give a comma and say
ascending equal to
false
say dot
and then
reset my index
for that i'll use reset underscore index
function
ok
let's check if everything is fine
i have
missed a square bracket here let me give
another square bracket here
okay
and all this we are going to store
in our
variable called top underscore 10
underscore active
underscore cases
okay
now let me go ahead and
run this cell
okay there is
a syntax error here
now let's run it okay
now i'll create another variable called
fig
here we'll pass in
the plt which is for matplotlib
library and we'll give the
figure size
using the
fig size
argument
it's equal to and within a tuple and
passing the size let's say 16 comma 9
we'll run it
okay
and
let's give
a title to our plot so here we are going
to create a
bar plot
so
using plt.title we'll pass in the
title let's say top 10 states
with
most
active cases in india
i'll give a comma and pass in the size
of my title
let's say 25
okay you can see we are slowly
being able to
create our graph
the most important thing is to pass in
the
x-axis and the y-axis
i'll say ax which is for axis to pass in
the axis i am going to use the bar plot
function that is present inside the c
bond library
i'll say sns.bar plot
i'll say data equal to
my
variable which is top underscore 10
underscore
states
this is actually active states
all right
and now
i'm going to use the
i lock
function
and
take the first 10 states so i'm using a
colon and then giving 10 as my value
iloc is for index location
i'll give a comma and say my
y axis to be
active cases
give another comma and say my x-axis to
be
state
slash
union territory
give another comma
we are going to pass in the line
width
to 2
i'll say line width equal to 2
and will give
an edge color
let's say the edge color is
red
okay
so i have my
access defined now
let's run it
there's an error here it says stopped in
active states not found
let's go to the top and see the exact
okay so this is
top 10 active cases let me change it to
cases here
now run it
okay the x axis also has a mistake this
should be
state slash union territory
now let me run it
there you go we have our
plot
created but as you can see here the
labels of the
different states and union territories
are overlapping so for that
let me first pass in the
x labels i'll say plt dot x
label
and my
x label would be states
then i'll say plt dot
by label
my y label will have the total
active cases
and finally i'll write plt dot show
before i run it let's collate all the
lines of code that we have written for
our
top 10 states for most active cases in
india into one cell
so what i'll do is i'll just copy this
and we'll keep
adding
in this cell itself
okay
i'll go to the top
next we'll copy
my figure size
and we'll
paste it here
next let's take the
title
and put it here
give us peace
and we are going to copy
this cell
and i'll paste it here
all right
now it's time to run it
there you go
you see it here
we have a nice
bar plot ready on the top you can see
the title top 10 states with most active
cases
and you see the edges are in red color
for all the bars
on the x-axis you have the different
state names maharashtra karnataka kerala
you also have andhra pradesh gujarat
west bengal and chatham
so as you can see
maharashtra
has the
highest number of active cases based on
our data followed by karnataka caroline
tamilnadu at second third and fourth
place respectively and in the ninth
place we have west bengal in the tenth
place we have chattisgarh
on the y-axis you can see the total
active cases
which are
in lakhs
okay
now moving ahead now we'll see the top
10 states based on the total number of
deaths reported
so i'll give a comment
top states
with
highest
debts
okay
so i'll first
create my variable
saying top 10 underscore
deaths
this will be very similar to
what we did here
just that we need to change a few
column names so instead of active cases
we'll be using
deaths
okay
so i'll start with my
data frame that is covered underscore df
followed by using the
group by function and i want to group my
data
based on
the state slash
union territory column
then i'll choose the max function
and within
double square brackets i'll pass in
my column names deaths and date
let's make it consistent i'll be using
single quotes
okay
i'll say dot
i'm gonna
short my
result therefore i am using the sort
underscore values function
i want to sort it by
deaths column
i'll give another comma and say
ascending equal to false which means i
want to
order my result in
descending order
then i'll say dot reset underscore index
okay
after that i'll give my
figure size i'll say plt dot figure
and within
brackets i'll pass in my argument which
is
fig size
equal to
using a tuple i'll say 18 comma let's
say 5
now let's give a title for that i'll use
the title function which is present in
the matplotlib library
i'll say
top 10 states with
most
deaths
and let's give a size to the title 25
now it's time for us to give the access
labels i'll just scroll down
okay
so i'll say ax equal to
again this will be a bar plot so i'm
using my c bond library followed by the
bar plot function
my data will be top
underscore 10 underscore depths
which is this variable
i'll give
my index location iloc
i'm going to choose
12 states the reason being
there are some discrepancies in the data
i'll show you once i plot this result
so in the y axis we'll have
depths column
in the x axis we'll take
state
slash
union territory
okay
i'll give another comma
and say
line width
equal to 2
and will give
an edge color to our
bars like we did here
so i'll say edge color
equal to let's say
black
okay
now
finally
we'll give
the x label the y label
so i'll say plt dot x label
x label would be states
my y label
will be
total
death cases
then i'll write plt dot show
now let's run it
there you go
you can see here we have a nice bar plot
on the top we have the title top 10
states with most deaths
now
what i specifically wanted you to
see was these discrepancies in the data
you can see here maharashtra is repeated
twice even
in our data that we collected from kegel
karnataka
spelling has an error you can see here
we have a few
rows of information where karnataka is
spelled as
k e r a a n instead of k e r n a
all right so to
remove
these
two results or to ignore these two
results i had given my index location
till 12 so we have
maharashtra karnataka tamil nadu delhi
then uttar pradesh west bengal kerala
punjab andhra pradesh and chhattisgard
with the states that have the
most number of deaths reported
okay
now we'll create a line plot to see
the
growth or the trend of active cases for
top five states with most number of
confirmed cases so the states are
maharashtra karnataka kerala tamil nadu
and uttar pradesh i can show you
so these are the states with
highest number of active cases
okay
i'll just give a comment saying
growth
trend
all right
so for that
we'll start with our figure size as
plt dot figure
i'll use my parameter fixed size equal
to
12 comma 6.
i'll say
my axis as sns dot
this time we are going to create a line
plot
my data would be
the original data frame that is covered
underscore df
and
within square brackets i'll say covad
underscore df
and we are going to pass in the
state or the union
territory column
i'll give
a dot and use the
is in function
so the
states should include
maharashtra
will give a comma the next state should
be
karnataka
next
we have
kerala
give another comma
my fourth state
is tamil nadu
give a comma
and my fifth state would be
uttar pradesh
all right
so i'll give
a comma here and then say
x equal to
the date column
y
will be
active cases column
and i'm going to use another parameter
called hue
which is to
give different colors to the different
states the five states that we are
looking for
so here
will be my
state slash
union territory column
okay
after this
i'll say
ax dot
set title
my title will be top five
affected
states
in india
we'll give a size let's say
16
all right okay this should be size equal
to 16
and
to make sure everything is fine let me
just
move it to the above line
okay
now we'll run it
okay there is some error again
it says
invalid syntax let's see where we went
wrong
let me bring this to the above line
okay this should be covered underscore
df
okay
make sure you
keep these small errors in check
let's try and run it again
all right
if i scroll down
there you go here you can see we have
the top five affected states in india
you see the
different
states here and the colors so
this violet or the purple color is for
maharashtra you can see
how the
active cases
searched around
april and may
and then you can see
even for karnataka the active cases
surged very rapidly
around may
and june
then it has decreased luckily
similarly you can see the plots for even
uttar pradesh
as well as for tamil nadu so all the
five states you can see one common trend
that
after march so around april
the cases started to emerge very rapidly
and
later after july they started dipping
okay
now
we are going to use our second data set
which is related to vaccination
all right
so first and foremost let me go ahead
and
print the data frame for you
so that you know
the data that we are going to use so
this is the data we are going to use
for our next
set of analysis
even this data has a few errors and you
can see there are a lot of missing
values it makes sense because not all
the days you would have
vaccination
for people
and
very crucial
error that we are going to deal with is
this
state column here you can see
in the state column we have india in a
few rows so we are going to ignore these
rows
all right
first let's rename
are updated on column to just
vaccine date
so
you can use the
rename function present in the pandas
library to do it so i'll say vaccine
underscore df dot
rename
i'll say columns equal to
within
curly braces
i'll write
updated
on
which is my
original column name
give a colon i want to change this to
vax vaccine underscore date
i'll give a comma
and say in place equal to true
so it will change
my
column name from updated on to vaccine
underscore date
in the
original data frame
let's run it
now
let me go ahead and print
the first
10 rows
in the data set
you can see here we have successfully
changed
the column name to vaccine underscore
date the rest of the columns remain the
same
all right
now you can
check
the
total number of
columns
rows
the data types and the memory usage
using the info function
here you can see it
we have total 24 columns
7845 entries
and these are the
columns that are present
and if i scroll further
you see here
says
the memory usage and here on the right
you can see the
data type
cool
now as you saw
the data has a lot of missing values
let's find the sum of all the missing
values for each column
so i'll say vaccine underscore df dot
is null
and then i'm going to use the sum
function over it
if i run it
there you go
so almost
all the columns
have missing values but columns such as
male individuals vaccinated female
individuals vaccinated even for columns
like
the age groups there are a lot of
missing values
now in the next step we are going to
drop a few
missing value columns
so i'll say
a new variable called vaccination
i'll give the data frame name vaccine
underscore df and use the drop function
and inside the drop function we are
going to write
columns equal to
i'll pass in the
column names that i want to drop
i'll say
doses
administered
so this is the column that i want to
delete sputnik v doses administered
i'll give a comma
the second column is e e
f i
the next column is
18 to 44
years
within bracket
it has doses
administered
give a comma
i'll say 45 to
60
years
doses
administered
to another comma the final column that
we are going to drop is
60 plus which is this one 60 plus years
doses
administered
okay
so these are the columns that we want to
drop
and finally i'll give my parameter
access equal to one
okay let me just recheck this column
names first one is sputnik v doses
administered then we have
efi
followed by
18 to 44 years dose is administered then
we have 45 to 60 years doses admin is
stored
finally we have 60 plus years
i've added
a s here which was missing and there
should be a space as well
because there's a space here in the
column now let's run it
all right
so we have successfully dropped
the columns that we wanted to drop
now i'll say vaccination dot head
you can see here
we have dropped those columns and we are
left with these columns now
okay
now
we are going to create a
plot
that is a pie plot to see
the vaccination for male and
female individuals so i'll give a
comment
as male versus
female vaccination
to create this pie plot i am going to
use the plotly library that we had
imported which is this one plotly
okay
so first of all we need to filter out
the
male individuals
from our data frame
i'll say male equal to
vaccination
meal
and passing in the column
individuals
vaccinated
we need to recheck the variable name
whether it is correct or not
you see here mail
individuals vaccinated
then i'll say
dot
sum
similarly we will filter out the female
individuals
i'll say female equal to
vaccination
which is my new data frame
within square brackets i'll pass in the
column name female
individual
vaccinated
i'll say dot sum
okay
okay these should be individuals as per
the
column name present in the data frame
cool
now i'm going to say px
dot pi function which is present in the
plotly library
i am going to
give the names of the
pies
so first one is mail
and the second one is
female
give a comma and say
values
equal to
male comma
female
then i'll give a comma and pass in my
title which is
male and
female vaccination
okay
this should be names
all right now let's go ahead and run
this cell
so it'll take some time to create the
pie chart here we go
see here i have my title male and female
vaccination
so these are the two
pies or the areas
you have the label female and the value
here you have the label meal and the
value
so from our data you can see 53 percent
male
individuals have been vaccinated
compared to 47 percent for females
okay now we are going to drop all those
rows where
our state was mentioned as india in the
original data set
i had shown this to you in the beginning
so we are going to remove
rows where
state is india
okay
so to do that i'll say
vaccine i'm creating another variable
called vaccine
and
we'll use our original data frame that
we had imported
which is vaccine underscore df
i'll
say vaccine underscore
df
dot
state
not equal to
india
now let's
print vaccine
okay you can see here we have our
data frame printed and from this data
frame we are taking only those values
or the rows where state is not equal to
india
cool
now what we are going to do is
we'll rename the last column which is
total individuals vaccinated to
just total
so i'll say vaccine dot
rename
we'll use the parameter columns equal to
within
curly braces i'll say
total
individuals
vaccinated
give a colon and we'll change this to
just total
give a comma and say in place equal to
true
and finally i'll print my
head of the new data frame
this should be columns equal to
okay
now you can see here if i scroll to the
right and if i check
we have successfully renamed our column
all right
now moving on to the last two
visualizations that we'll see in this
first project using python that is to
find the states with most number of
vaccinated individuals and the state
with the least number of vaccinated
individuals
okay
just give a comment
most
vaccinated
state
okay
for this i'll first create a variable
called wax underscore
vac which is for maximum vaccination
i'm going to use my
data frame vaccine
followed by the group by function
i want to grip it by state column
and
we'll find the total sum
of vaccinated individuals
for each state
i'll convert this to frame
there should be a dot
to underscore frame
and i'll pass in my column name which is
total
after that
i'll say max underscore vac
equal to
max underscore vac dot
short
underscore values
i'm going to sort it by
my total column
and say ascending equal to false which
means i want to sort it in descending
order
so that we have the
states with the
highest number of
individuals vaccinated
i want the top five states
now
let's go ahead and
print it
so this will create a nice table for us
there you go
here you can see
we have maharashtra uttar pradesh
rajasthan gujarat in west bengal as the
top five states with most number of
vaccinated individuals
now we are going to use this table and
convert it into a
chart
now i had already written my
code for the
bar plot i'm just going to paste it
so here i have defined my
figure size as 10 comma 5
then i'm giving a title as top 5
vaccinated states in india and the size
is 20
after that i have created a variable
called x
which is going to store my bar plot
this bar plot we have created using the
c bond library
and
you see here i have my
y-axis defined
then
i have the line width and the edge color
as well
i have given my x-label as states by
label as vaccination and i'm finally
going to display my plot so let's go
ahead and run it
okay you can see it here
we have converted this
table into a bar plot now
so first we have maharashtra with the
highest
number of vaccination
then we have uttar pradesh rajasthan
gujarat and west bengal
now
i want
the viewers
watching this video to
find the states with least number of
vaccinated individuals and convert that
table into a
bar plot that will show the
bottom five vaccinated states in india
which means the states which have
least number of individuals vaccinated
so please go ahead and put your
codes in the comment section of the
video it will be very similar to these
two cells just that now we want to know
the least five vaccinated states in
india
so please put the code snippets in the
comments section of this video we'll be
more than happy to know from you in case
you are not able to do it we'll
definitely keep the answers in the
comments itself
all right so this brings us to the end
of the first
project on kovit data analysis using
python
so
in this project we used two data sets
one was on
the covet 19
india data set for different states and
union territories and the second data
set that we used was for
analyzing the status of vaccination in
the different states in india
now we'll move on to our second project
okay so before moving on to our tableau
project let's see the final quiz
which of the following is not a common
coronavirus symptom so this question is
to make you aware of the correct coveted
symptoms
here are the options
is it a fever
b
vision loss c loss of taste and smell or
is it d cup
please put your answers in the comments
section of the video and let us know
what you think
now we'll move on to our second govi
data analysis project
for this project we'll be using the
tableau software and a global
coronavirus data set
first we look at the data set and the
fields we have
okay so i am in my data set folder
we have already seen the first two data
sets in our
python project
this time we are going to use the global
covet data let me open it
all right so here you can see
we have the different country names
there are
192 countries in our data set
let me go to the top
so
we have
country or region
we also have the code
for each of the countries
then we have column called last updated
so here you can see our data is still
12th of march 2021
and there are two columns which
don't have any information that is
people hospitalized and people
tested
then we have a column called
active cases then we have a column for
confirmed cases
in the different
countries we have the number of deaths
and then we have the incident rate
the latitude and the longitude for the
countries
then we have the mortality rate
this is in fractions
then we have the number of
recovered cases and finally we have a
column called uid
so we'll be mostly using the country
column
active
confirmed deaths
and the recovered cases column
and we'll be using the tableau software
to create interesting visualizations and
we'll convert those visuals and put it
in the form of a dashboard
towards the end of the project
okay so let me
close this file or let it be open
i'll search for tableau public
you can see here i have
tableau public installed
you can use the
desktop version of tableau or the public
version of tableau
so for this project we are going to use
the tableau
public edition
so here you can see i have
created a few visuals already
if you want you can clear them out
okay
now
the first thing we need to do is to
connect our csv data set to tableau for
that
under connect
we have to a file
i'm going to use
text file
and under
chrome downloads so i'll search for my
folder covered
india
and here i have my
global covet data file let me open it
this will take some time to load
there you can see
so on the tableau you can see the view
here
it shows the country or the region
you have the last update
you have columns like active confirmed
that's
mortality rate and recovered
and here you can see the
symbols for the
different columns so this is
a globe which means this field
is a region or a
geographic field
abc means it's a text field then we have
the calendar which is for a date field
abcr
text field and this
hash represents
numeric fields
all right
so now that we have loaded our data
let me just click on sheet1
so this is the canvas where we are going
to create our different
reports
all right
so on the left you can see there are two
panes the data pane and the analytics
pane
in the data pane you can see the
name of the data set global covet data
and here you can see the
different columns that we have in the
data set so on the top
the ones marked in
blue are called as dimensions
and at the bottom
whatever you see
are marked in green and are called as
measures
so
dimensions are always represented with
blue icons and measures are in green
icons
so
tableau has automatically detected the
different
data types for each of the
columns
all right
so
first of all we are going to create a
simple table
to see the total number of confirmed
cases for each of the
countries
so for that i'm going to drag my country
or the region column onto rows
here you have rows i'll just drag it and
drop it here
there you go it has populated all my
country names starting from afghanistan
so it has ordered in
ascending order of alphabets
now to
see the total confirmed cases for each
country i am going to drag my confirmed
column onto text so here under marks
card you have
the text option i'll just drag it
and drop it here
there you go
so tableau how easily has
shown me a table where you can see the
different country names and on the right
you have the total number of cases that
have emerged
from these countries
now this is not the most recent data as
i told you this data was till march
2021.
cool
now you can go ahead and
short the
table based on the
total confirmed cases here on the top
you can see here
there are two options to sort in
ascending order or in descending order
let's first sort in
ascending order
by sum of confirmed cases within country
and region
there you go so here you can see
these are the countries which have very
few cases
and if i scroll down
you have france uk russia brazil india
and u.s with the highest number of
kovite 19 cases
if you want you can also
short it in
descending order so that the countries
with the highest number of confirmed
cases appear at the top you can see it
here
and these are the countries that have
very few covet cases
now you can convert this simple table
into different charts and graphs
to do that
here on the
right top corner you have an option
called show me
now
i can just click on
this horizontal bar graph
so that will automatically convert my
table into a bar graph
again you can go ahead and
short the data
there you go
so here you have u.s india brazil russia
uk france spain and italy this is a
horizontal bar graph
sorted in
descending order of confirmed cases
now suppose you want to display only the
top few countries with the highest
number of confirmed cases for that you
can select these bars
so i'll select till let's say
germany
or let's say to argentina
okay and i'll click on keep only you can
see it here it says 12 items selected
that is the sum of confirmed cases i'll
just click on keep only
there you go
so
this horizontal bar graph has
information only for these
few countries that have the highest
number of confirmed cases
now you can go ahead and
play with the color formatting
so here under colors let me choose
a green color
okay
now you can mark here since we selected
only the top 12 countries with the
highest number of confirmed cases so
what we did was we just filtered it to
the top 12 countries so tableau has
automatically added country region in
the
filters card
now if you want you can go ahead and
edit this filter as well
suppose you want to remove argentina you
can just uncheck this click on apply and
okay you see here argentina has been
removed i click on
undo so ctrl z to get it back cool
now you can convert this
horizontal bar plot into a vertical bar
plot let me show you how to do it i'll
just remove these
fields from my
chart
now what i'm going to do is i'll
drag country or region onto columns
and i'll have
confirmed
column under rows
there you go here you can see we have
a vertical bar plot now
and again you can
use the access now to short your data
this is in
descending order similarly you can sort
it in ascending order here you have the
option to
sort your data
okay
cool
and below you can see the
different country names
all right
now you can go ahead and
give
a name to this sheet
let's say
top 10
confirmed
countries
to supply
and click on ok you have the title to
this plot
similarly you can change it here as well
top 10
confirmed
countries
okay
now let's move on to our second
visualization where we will create a
global map so this global map will show
the different countries
present
in the map and the cases that they have
so to create the map first i'll drag my
longitude
generated field onto columns and then
i'll drag latitude on to rows
you see here we have the map ready
and now
i'll drag
country region onto detail
so this will give you
the different country names you can see
here we have canada
the united states
mexico
here you have india
sri lanka
there's australia
this is brazil
and similarly we have spain france
belgium
there's
italy here we have also greece
similarly we have the african countries
like
central african republic this congo
angola
and on the top you have russia and this
is iceland
so on and so forth
now
i'm going to drag
the
active cases column onto
detail again
now if i hover the cursor you can see
the
active numbers for brazil you can see
for india
you have
countries like china
then here you have thailand
algeria
now
i'm going to drag the confirmed cases
column on to label
so that you have the labels here you can
see here the confirmed labels
cool
now if you only want to focus on a few
countries
present in a particular region you can
highlight that region for example
suppose
for europe you want to focus on this
region if you select it it will
highlight only those countries and if
you hover your mouse over these points
it will show you the active cases and
the total number of confirmed cases
all right now if you want you can go
ahead and change the color of the
circles let's see i'll keep it as
red
okay
so this is how you can create a
map to represent the different active
and
confirmed cases
i'll rename the title to
global
cases
i'll just click on apply and okay
similarly i'll change the sheet name as
well to
global cases
okay
now from this map you can see the
countries such as usa
brazil
you have russia
and india with the
highest number of kovit 19 cases even in
countries such as
spin the numbers are
really high
and
a lot of the african countries were also
impacted
and these small countries like solomon
islands you have
fizzy islands
with few number of cases even for new
zealand as well
all right
now moving to our next
visual
now we are going to see the top 10
countries where highest debts have been
reported so far due to the pandemic for
this we will create a tree map now
so first of all i'll
choose my country column and
put it under
columns
and then i'll select
the deaths column and put it under rows
i have the
bar plot ready
next i'll go to show me and here i have
the option to select a tree map
you see here for a tree map you need one
or more dimensions and one or two
measures so i'll just click on this tree
map
okay here you can see i have my tree map
ready so tableau has automatically
adjusted my fields so it has removed my
fields from rows and columns and put it
under size color and
label
next i will drag my
country column and put it under filters
and from here
i am going to choose top
i'll filter by field i'm going to select
the top 10
countries
based on the total number of
deaths
just click on apply and click on ok
so
these are the countries us brazil mexico
india united kingdom italy russia spain
france germany
which have the highest number of deaths
reported
now
you can also
give the label
i'll
put the debts column under label so that
you have the labels here
all right so this was a tree map that we
created to show the
top 10 countries with the highest
number of deaths
i'll just
change the title top 10
deaths
cases
now you can also edit the title in terms
of the font color and everything
that's i'll keep it taboo bold
and i'll choose this as 14 click on
apply and okay
there you go similarly let's
rename the sheet to
death cases
cool
now moving
to the next visualization where we'll
see
about the recoveries
so before we move on to
create a visualization for the
top 10 or let's say the bottom 10
countries in terms of recoveries let me
show you how to change the
color of the stream app
so here
by default tableau select the automatic
palette
if you want you can change it to
different
palettes let's see i'll go with
gold purple diverging
click on apply and i'll click on ok
if this is
not looking
that great you can select another one
let's say
red green white diverging
cool
now let's
go to our
fourth visualization which is about
10
recoveries
i'll click on apply and ok
first i'll drag my country or the region
column
under
columns
and then i'll take
the recovered column under rows
this time
instead of
sum we are going to choose
average
okay
and here
i'll select
my packed
bubble chart
after that i am going to drag my country
or region onto colors
and then i'll also
put country under filters
so i'll go to
the top
menu
and i'll filter it by field
i want to show the top 10 countries
based on the average number of
recoveries so click on apply and okay
you can see here these are the countries
that have
the highest number of
average recoveries you have india brazil
turkey italy argentina germany colombia
russia poland and mexico
i'll just rename this sheet to
recovery cases
cool
now let's move on to our next visual
okay
so here we are going to create a scatter
plot to analyze the total confirmed
cases versus the total number of deaths
so whenever you have two numeric fields
it is better to create a scatter plot to
visualize the cases
so for that i am going to
drag my confirmed
cases to columns and then i will drag
my
depth column onto
rows
okay
so by default
the shape is a circle
and
to see all the countries i am going to
drag country under color
i'll say add all members
there you go
here
you can see the legend
for the different
countries
and
the top you have
us with the highest number of confirmed
cases and the highest number of
deaths as per our data set
then you also have brazil here which has
the
second highest number of deaths
then you have
mexico
followed by india
so this data is not a very recent data
this data was last updated on
march
now from this we are going to filter out
the top 10 countries with the highest
number of
confirmed cases
and the deaths
so for that i'll drag my country column
onto filters and i'll go to top
filter by field
i'll say top 10
and i'll click on apply and ok
so here you can see we have siberia
sweden
belgium
netherlands
spain
italy france russia
uk and
you have brazil
so these are the countries which have
the
highest number of
active cases
so instead of active let's select deaths
click on apply and okay
okay
now if you see we have us here
brazil india
then mexico
uk russia france
italy germany and spain which have the
highest number of deaths reported so far
now if you want you can
change
the
size of the circles based on the
highest number of active cases so i can
just drag my active column under size
so you can see here
spin
france
uk have the highest number of active
cases
now let's say instead of active i'll
just have
my confirmed cases under size
okay
and then
you can also change the shape from
circle to
any other shape let's say square or
this asterisk
okay let's go with the triangle
cool
i'll rename this sheet to
confirmed versus
depths
click on apply and ok
i'll rename this to
confirmed
versus
deaths
alright
now moving on to our
next visualization where we will see
the mortality
for each of the countries
and figure out which countries have the
highest mortality rate
okay
so
first i'll drag
mortality rate
onto column
and then i'll have
my
country column under rows
so there you go
now let me go ahead and
sort it in
descending order
so you can see here you have yemen
there is mexico syria sudan egypt
equator china and other countries which
have the highest mortality rate
and you can also
select the country
region under colors
let's go ahead and edit the
color
instead of automatic let's select summer
or
you can go for some other palette let's
say
tableau
classic medium i'll assign this palette
yes i'll apply and okay
all right
finally
we'll
move ahead to our
last visualization where we'll create a
dual access chart
so the dual axis chart in tableau will
have one column and two different
visualizations on the rows so here you
have
one
column and on the right also you'll have
one column with their own access values
so this dual axis chart will be for
recovered cases and the
death cases
let me show you how to do it
so i'll drag
my country
field onto
columns
and then
i'll choose
recovered column onto
rows
so here i have got my
line chart
and the second
column i'm going to choose is the depths
column
i'll hold my
cursor and i'll place it
when i get this
green color rectangle i'll place it here
there you go
so now we have created two measure names
deaths and
recovered
and here you have the access values
you can synchronize the access values if
you want
the recovered cases are in millions and
the deaths are in thousands
now let's go ahead and
change
the
recovered line to
bars and
we're going to short it
okay
now let's change the color
we'll select let's say
blue i'll assign the palette click on
apply and okay
and if you want you can also change the
color
for
depths from blue to let's say
winter i'll assign the palette click on
apply and okay
you can have whichever color you want
and to make the access seam you can just
right click on this axis and click on
synchronize access
so here you can see the values
let's keep it in thousands only
cool
i'll rename this sheet to
dual access
okay
now
before we move ahead and create our
final dashboard i want to show you
one more
feature in tableau that is to format the
labels so you can see here
instead of writing 5 lakh 30 821 we can
change this in terms of millions or
thousands and write it as let's say 530k
to do that
what i'll do is i'll go to format and
here we have the option
to select
font
and in font i'll go to fields and
click on sum of deaths
and here
in this pane
i'll choose
number custom
decimal places will be 0
and display units i'll select
thousands
you can see here the values have been
changed to 531k 193k 158k
so on and so forth
cool
now let's go ahead and create our final
dashboard here is the option to create a
new dashboard so i'll just click on
new dashboard
and we are going to increase the
size here so that
it fits our
view
so we have selected the default view and
the size i am going to
choose here is automatic so now we can
drop our sheets one by one
first let's drag the
global cases
sheet here
okay you can see we have our map
now
i'm going to choose the top 10 confirmed
cases
all right
and after that we'll choose the
death cases sheet so tableau will prompt
you to place the sheet
at the right location
okay
and now
i'll choose my
fifth visual which is confirmed versus
deaths
and if you want you can choose any one
of
these let's say i'll take the dual axis
chart
now you can just
minimize the
sheets and adjust the
sizes to
make it look better
okay
so you can see here we have our
dashboard ready now you can still go
ahead and customize the dashboards in
terms of adding different
filters to it we are not going to
show that now you are getting some
messages here to unknown for nulls you
can
remove them as well
and here on the top you have the option
to
click on the presentation mode
the hugo so this is our final dashboard
that we have created
all right so this brings us to the end
of the
second
coronavirus data analysis project using
tableau
now you can just click on escape to go
back
all right now you can save this
and
this will be published in the
tableau public
platform under your profile
so that brings us to the end of this
video tutorial on kobe data analysis
project using python and tableau i hope
it was useful and informative please try
to answer the quizzes that you saw in
this video
thank you for watching and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here